-Our next guest is a very funn
comedian who you know from
his Donald Trump impressio
on "The President Show,"
which is streaming on
CBS All Access.
His daily talk show
"Coffee with Tony" airs weekdays
at 12:30 p.m. Eastern on Twitch.
Please welcome back to the sho
Anthony Atamanuik.
How are you, Anthony?
-Hello. How's it going, Seth
-It's going great.
You are in Canada,
shooting
"What We Do in the Shadows."
Fantastic show. How is Canada?
-Well, Canada's cold.
Canada's an apartment.
Canada is not more than just
an apartment,
a nondescript apartment
that looks --
This is where I do
my therapy also, on Zoom,
so it's a very comfortable place
for me.
I will say
that I brought everything
I own because I drove here
So I brought my coffee maker
my Xbox, I brought my VR system.
-[ Laughs ]
-I brought
my blood pressure monitor.
[ Laughter ]
-That's great.
-Which I don't need.
I don't need it.
But yeah.
It's crazy coming here because
there was nothing at the borde
'cause they don't
really want you here
'cause you're
a diseased American.
-I'm very happy
that you're there
and that you're safe
and that you're working.
You know, we --
I want to talk about --
and the last time you were her
we talked about
"The President Show,"
which is a fantastic show,
where you play Donald Trump.
And one of the things,
one of the ways clips resurfac
is based on how prescient
your show was
predicting certain things
to happen,
up to and including the fact
that you were always
of the belief that Donald Trum
would not concede
if he lost an election.
-Yeah. Since the --
I think since I did my live show
in 2015.
That was always predicated
that he wouldn't --
he would never --
you know, listen.
I always find this interesting
because you have
this piece of history with the
correspondents' dinner with him.
And then there's sort of
this propulsion that happens
And to me, I always
look at it and go,
"How did everyone not see
what was going to happen?"
To me, I don't see it
as I predicted something.
I feel like everyone was
just in such disbelief tha
such a drop-jawed moron coul
end up being the president
and then coast through the job
for four years
without ever doing anything.
I think my favorite part
was near the end
where people were like, "What'
the President going to do?
The commentate-- the news --
"What's the President
going to do?"
It's like, "Nothing."
He hasn't done anything
for four years.
Why is he going to start now
Even the fact that he just
like, slipped out lazily,
did one last YMCA, like some
like, aunt at a bar mitzvah,
that is like -- the fact tha
that was his choice near the end
was like, "I'm going to projec
masculinity and control
and power by waving my arm
pumping my arms in the air."
But yeah, so I was
not surprised.
That's way off topic.
But I'm not surprised at all
that he didn't concede.
I mean, obviously him being,
you know --
the things we depicted
in the show,
some of them were
very metaphorical.
But we did actually predict hi
coming out the night
of the election and saying
"I did not lose. I won."
And then we had this timelin
of, like, protests and thing
slowly declining
over the next couple of months
And that was like a segmen
we did in the show.
And it's pretty haunting.
And I remember when we made it
my producers were like,
"I don't know.
This seems like
a little too harsh.
I think it's a little too much."
And I was like, "No, this
will be nothing compared t
what actually happens."
-This was a clip that
it made a lot of sense
that people were posting,
but here is you as Donald Trum
literally being rolled out
of the Oval Office.
[ Laughter ]
I -- you mentioned that --
I think that --
news commentators went sort of
this cycle of trying to give him
a chance over and over again
"This will be different.
This will be different."
And, you know, your show
is a perfect example of,
no, there is no reason to thin
someone that made it this fa
in his life being this
would ever be something else
-Yeah.
-How is it that you approached
the impression that made i
different from everybody els
and set it apart?
-Well, you grew up
in New England.
You have family members that
you've known their entire live
are obstinately locked in
who they are
and that they never change
And that's everywhere,
but New England has a particular
population of these people
And so I think that it was -- As
a New Englander, I can say that.
I approached him
like a combination of obstinance
that's calcified in who he is.
And I guess my goal
always in playing him
and doing the impression -
I don't know why I'm screaming
-[ Laughs ]
-Reminds me of
doing the impression.
Was that I wanted to
sort of take
Chaplin's "The Great Dictator,
right?
Where you portray the figure
but then you break from
that character
and, like, speak truth
but through the image of
the character
'cause in my view, I knew that
a Comedy Central show
wasn't gonna change
the course of history
or anything like that.
But I thought, if at least I
could chisel and chip away
at that image, which his image
is projecting this, you know
big, tough, business guy,
so I wanted to make him
what I think he is,
which is like the fifth
Golden Girl, you know?
He's just like sort of,
you know --
he's, like, in a housecoat
eating cheesecake,
you know, yelling at Ma
and wondering why
Blanche is home late.
That's all he really is.
And everyone wants him
to be something else
because they're wrapping their
identities up in his success
He's just a manifestation of
an American narrative
that's lasted --
began long before Reagan
but really calcified in Reagan
of this lottery mentality,
that "if I just play
my cards right,
I can just be the big success,
right?
And I think it's broken down
our society,
and we see the result now,
where if everyone's
playing scratchers all the time,
then yeah, so one person
wins a million,
but everyone else is just brok
with a bunch of, like, silve
shavings on their thumbs.
And I think
that's where we're at.
We're sort of like the guy
who's, you know, or woman
at the Cumberland Farms
who, like, has scratched,
you know, 500 tickets,
and they're just abject.
So they're willing to believ
in some sort of Q god, you know.
-I have more
to talk to you about,
especially in regards
to impeachment.
We'll be right back with
more from Anthony Atamanuik.